[موسيقى]
السلام عليكم واهلا بكم زار وفد اسرائيلي
برئاسه مديره اداره الشرق الاوسط في
الخارجيه القاهره قبل ايام من زياره
للرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس ياتي ذلك بعد
دعوه الرئيس المصري عبد فتاح السيسي الى
ما سماه سلاما دافئا بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين واعتبر مبادره مصريه لاحياء
عمليه السلام بين الجانبين نتوقف مع هذا
الخبر لنناقش في
محورين ما الغرض من طرح مبادره السيسي في
ظل تفاقم ازمات حكمه وتزايد هيمنه اليمين
المتطرف على صناعه القرار
الاسرائيلي وكيف يمكن تفسير مسارعه
نتنياهو الى الترحيب مبادره السيسي في
مقابل رفضه مبادره فرنسيه لاحياء عمليه
[موسيقى]
السلام السلام الدافئ بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين هذا ما دع له الرئيس المصري
عبد الفتاح السيسي في مبادره جديده قال ان
هدفها احياء عمليه السلام بين الجانبين
ويبدو ان الاسرائيليين اكثر ميلا الى ما
اقترحه الرئيس المصري مما حمله اليهم رئيس
وزراء فرنسا
داعيا الى مؤتمر دولي للسلام كان يؤمل ان
تحتضنه باريس الاسبوع المقبل ويطرح السؤال
بالحاح عن قدره مبادره السيسي على اذابه
الجليد بين الفلسطينيين والحكومه
الاسرائيليه وقد زادتها تحالفاتها الاخيره
تطرفا على تطرف نتابع هذا التقرير للزميل
ناصر ايه
الطاهر الدفء الذي تعد به القاهره يستهوي
الاسرائيليين فماذا يحمل وفدهم الذي يضم
قيادات من الخارجيه والامن ويلف الكتمان
زيارته الى العاصمه
المصريه قد تناقش الزياره كما قيل وضع
قوات حفظ السلام في سيناء والاوضاع
الامنيه هناك ولعل لدى الوفد مقترحات ذات
صله بمبادره الرئيس المصري الاخيره لدفع
السلام بين الفلسطينيين والاسرائيليين
برعايه
مصريه اطلق عبد الفتاح السيسي مبادرته تلك
التي لم يفصل فيها في اجواء من التودد لتل
ابيب استفزت كثيرا من المصريين كان خطابا
نادرا توجه فيه بشكل مباشر الى
الاسرائيليين دعاهم الى احياء عمليه
السلام بالعوده الى طاوله المفاوضات حتى
يعم الاستقرار المنطقه لكن اليس ذلك ما
تنشده مبادره السلام العربيه التي اطلقت
قبل اكثر من عقد من الزمن لا يعرف ما اذا
كان السي
تمدي لما اقترحه العرب في قمه بيروت عام
200 ولا يعرف لما تتحرك القاهره الان وسط
حديث عن تعديل محتمل لتلك
المبادره قبل ذلك يتساءل قطاع واسع من
الفلسطينيين يشارك السيسي في حصارهم عما
اذا كان الرجل في موقع يؤهله لاي وساطه
اما في اسرائيل فالامر مختلف كلمات غذت
هناك حماسه جاءت كما يبدو على حساب مبادره
سلام اخرى يقودها
الفرنسيون ترفض الحكومه الاسرائيليه بشكل
صريح المبادره الفرنسيه القاضيه بعقد
مؤتمر سلام دولي في باريس وهي الان اشد
ميلا الى ما يقترحه السيسي فهل يكفي ذلك
حافزا يعجل بزياره رئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى القاهره ام هل ان السيسي
سيفعلها فيبادر ب زياره اسرائيل سيرا على
خطى الرئيس الراحل انور السادات وذاك ما
قال البعض انه سيكون بمثابه انتحار سياسي
مبكر لا يخفي الاعلام الاسرائيلي وجود
ترتيبات للقاء يجمع في القاهره كلا من
الرئيس المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي والرئيس
الفلسطيني محمود عباس ورئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي بن يمين
نتنياهو محض اكاذيب تقول مصادر في السلطه
الفلسطينيه
واذا لم يكن الامر كذلك فان القمه
الثلاثيه ستعرض عليها على الارجح رؤيه
للحل تجرب بلورتها كما يعتقد في مشاورات
مكثفه مع
الامريكيين يقول مبعوث لجنه الرباعيه
السابق توني بلير ان هناك كثيرا يتوقف على
استجابه الحكومه الاسرائيليه لمبادره
الرئيس السيسي
ولمبادئ حكومه في اسرائيل لم تفلح كل
المساعي في جعلها اقل
تطرفا لمناقشه موضوع هذه الحلقه معنا من
تورونتو الدكتور ثروه نافع عضو لجنه
الدفاع والامن القومي في مجلس الشورى
المصري السابق ومن نابلس عبد الستار قاسم
الكاتب والمحلل السياسي ومن القاهره عبر
سكايب مجدي شندي رئيس تحرير صحيفه المشهد
الاسبوعيه نرحب بضيوفنا الكرام ولعلنا
نبدا من تورونتو معك دكتور ثروت ونود ان
نعرف بدايه وفقا لقراءتك ما الذي يمكن ان
يدفع السيسي لطرح مبادره تزاحم مبادره
فرنسيه موجوده اصلا في ظل تفاقم ازماته
الداخليه
اصلا لم يعد خافيا على احد ان اكثر من روج
للنظام الانقلابي برئاسه عبد الفتاح
السيسي في مصر للدول في الخارج كانت
الدوله الصهيونيه اسرائيل يعني هذا ليس
افتراء يعني او ادعاء هذا تم اعلانه من
قبل الاداره الامريكيه والكونج الامريكي
وكذلك الاتحاد الاوروبي وكذلك اسرائيل ولم
تنكره القاهره و وقد استمعنا يعني بانفسنا
لبعض المسؤولين في الخارج وهم يعني يذكرون
ذلك بان اكثر من روج وكان يعني يدعو
للاعتراف بنظام السيسي كانت سفراء اسرائيل
في الدول الاوروبيه
والامريكيه ومن المؤسف ان نظام عبد الفتاح
السيسي هو اكثر الانظمه
الذي يعني جاءت بنظريه حرق الارض ولا
تعترف باي ثوابت وطنيه او
قوميه وتنازلت عن معظم الحقوق سواء كانت
في الحدود او كانت في ارساء الفكر العسكري
او او او الفكر من ان العدو الاساسي ليس
ابناء الوطن الواحد ولكن العدو الاساسي هو
اسرائيل المؤلم ايضا ان ان اتجاه اسرائيل
لمبادره عبد الفتاح السيسي اكثر من
الاتحاد الاوروبي ان اننا نعيش الان عصرا
عبد الفتاح السيسي يقدم لاسرائيل ما لا
تقد ما لا يقدمه الاتحاد الاوروبي من
تنازلات يعني المؤلم اننا نرى ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي يتبنى القضيه من وجهه نظر الى حد
ما اوبجكتف او موضوعيه اكثر من وجهه نظر
عبد الفتاح السيسي التي تتبنى وجهه النظر
اليمين المتطرف الاسرائيلي دع نتحول للسيد
عبد الستار قاسم يعني من وجهه نظر
فلسطينيه هل السيسي فعلا يمكن اعتباره
وسيط نزيه وعراب لمبادره سلام هو المتهم
بانه منحاز ضد القضيه الفلسطينيه تحديدا
في حصار غزه هناك الكثير من التساؤلات
والاتهامات بهذا الخصوص سيد عبد
الستار هو يعتمد عن اي فلسطيني
تتحدثين انت تعلمين اننا
منقسمون وبالتالي المواقف متعدده في
الساحه الفلسطينيه اما من الواضح ان السيد
السيسي يحاول بقدر الامكان ان يعمق عمليه
التطبيع مع اسرائيل وهو يفتح ابواب مصر
مشرعه امام النشاطات الاسرائيليه لمزيد من
التطبيع وطبعا شكرا للجان مقاومه التطبيع
المصريه التي نجحت حتى الان في منع هذا
الهوس الرئاسي نحو اسرائيل اما بالنسبه
للفلسطينيين يعني اجمالا السلطه
الفلسطينيه لا تستطيع ان تقول لا لمبادرات
السيسي لاسباب داخليه وتوازنات عربيه وما
شابه ذلك لكن الذين يؤيدون
المقاومه في فلسطين انما ياخذون على
السيسي عمليه الحصار بالاساس حصار غزه مصر
تخنق غزه تخنق الشعب الفلسطيني في غزه
طبعا هذا لا ينفي انه اسرائيل هي تقوم
بعمليه الحصار لكن الذي يعزز الحصار ويؤدي
الى هذا التدهور الخطير في غزه هي مصر هي
لا تفتح المعبر الا بالقطاره وبعد يعني
اشهر والى اخره فضلا عن انه قطعت الكثير
من القدرات او من الامكانات التي كان يمكن
ان تحصل عليها غزه لمواجهه اسرائيل ا غزه
كانت تهرب وربما الرئيس المصري حسني مبارك
كان يغض الطرف احيانا اما السيسي ابدا هو
متزمت ومتصلب ولا يريد ان يترك الهواء
يدخل الى غزه تما فالناس ياخذون على
الرئيس المصري مثل هذه الاعمال ويقولون
انه يقزم دور مصر في الوطن العربي اذا
تقزم لدور مصر في الوطن العربي وفق العديد
من الرؤى وهذا ما طرحه ضيفنا الكريم السيد
عبد الستار سيد مجدي شندي ان كان الوضع
بهذه الطريقه وقد سمعت مختلف الاراء في
هذه الحلقه نود ان نتس ساء ايا كانت نوايا
السيسي من وراء هذه المبادره التي يطرحها
مزاحمه لمبادره فرنسيه بغطاء دولي نتساءل
هل يملك السيسي ايه اوراق ضغط على اسرائيل
وهي واقع الامر يقول بانها من يملك دفترا
من اوراق الضغط على السيسي بدء من سيناء
وصولا الى تسويقه في
واشنطن اولا ليس مطلوبا منا ان ناخذ ما
يقوله ضيوفك على انه من المسلمات هذا ليس
مسلمات على اي نحو السيسي يستكمل الدور
المصري تجاه القضيه الفلسطينيه وهو دور
تاريخي ولا يمكن لاحد ان يزايد عليه يعني
عفوا اراء ضيوفنا محترمه لان لديها ما
يساندها عفوا سيد مجدي الجميع يعلم ما
فعلته مصر السيسي ب بخصوص حصار قطاع غزه
وليس هذا الا جزء من العديد من الاشياء
نهيك عن السلام الدافئ الذي بات يبحث معه
مع
الاسرائيليين يعني دعينا بس نضع النقاط
فوق الحروف السيسي كان رئيسا للمخابرات
العسكريه
في نهايات زمن مبارك ولم يكن قطاع
غزه يشتكي في تلك الفتره او في الفتره
التي اعقبت ثوره خم 20 يناير من حصار
والرجل هو كان المسؤول الاول لكن بدا
اغلاق القطاع بعد تفشي اعمال الارهاب في
سيناء وبعد ان بدا الارهابيون يستغلون
الانفاق لهروب من ايدي السلطات المصريه
فعلينا ان نربط بين الامور وبعضها البعض
لا نحاول ان ناخذ لقطه على انها وهل يملك
ايه اوراق ضغط لاجبار اسرائيل على قبول
هذا السلام الذي يريده وفقا لمقايسه ويبدو
ان لا احد مقتنع بحتى الفلسطينيين
انفسهم لا مبادره السيسي دعت الى مصالحه
فلسطينيه اولا ومعنى المصالحه ان تتفق
حركتي فتح وحماس وهما الحركتان الكبيرتان
في النضال الوطني الفلسطيني
ومعنى هذه المصالحه هي تقويه لعضد القضيه
الفلسطينيه لعضد النضال الفلسطيني حتى اذا
ما بدات مفاوضات سلام مع الكيان الصهيوني
يكون الفلسطينيون موقفهم قويا والقضيه
الفلسطينيه هي جوهر الصراعات كلها في
المنطقه هي سبب تحريك كل الفتن وكل
الازمات وربما
ياتي طرح هذه الدعوه وهي ليست مبادره
لانها لا بنود لها حتى هذه اللحظه ولا
تفاصيل لها وهذا ما يجعلنا نتسائل فعليا
بانه لا تفاصيل اطلاقا لهذه المبادره او
الدعوه سميها ما شات والتي جاءت في الواقع
في اعقاب خطاب السيسي اتحول الان للدكتور
ثروه نافع هذا الخطاب الذي كشفت الصحافه
الاسرائيليه مباشره بعد دكتور ثروت بانه
يهدف لتقليل منسوب التطرف في الحكومه
الاسرائيليه وذلك من خلال محاوله لضم
المعسكر الصهيوني بزعامه هيرتسوغ اليها
والتمهيد بذلك لاحياء عمليه السلام
المنشوده الرد جاء سريعا اسرائيليا
والجميع يعلم بانه تم ضم ليبرمان المتطرف
الاكثر تطرفا من التطرف بعينه الم يتلقى
السيسي
الرساله ا اذا كان هذا مفهوم الصحافه
الاسرائيليه فبالطبع هذه اهانه لمصر انه
للاسف هو من يمثل مصر الان عبد الفتاح
السيسي في النظام الدولي والعالمي واذا
كان هو يروج لاحد اجنحه السياسه
الاسرائيليه من خلال خطاب يوجه اليه منهم
فدي شيء مهين ان الصحافه الاسرائيليه تقول
كده وانا اصدق الصحافه الاسرائيليه للاسف
اكثر من من معظم الصحافه المصريه الان
التي توجه من خلال مدير مكتب عبد الفتاح
السيسي الشيء
الاخر عبد الفتاح السيسي دعى الى سلام
دافئ سواء كانت مبادره او دعوه في في كل
الاحوال نحن اعتدنا على من نظام عبد
الفتاح السيسي ان يفاجئ المصريين باشياء
تم الاعداد لها لشهور
وتم الانتهاء منها وليس حتى الاعداد لها
كما فعل في تيران وصنافير وغيرهما وكما
فعل في الحدود البحريه مع قبرس وكما فعل
في اشياء اخرى وكما فعل في سد النهضه فهو
دائما ما يجري كل شيء بعقليه ضابط الجيش
او المخابرات ثم ا يعلنها او او يعلن
نتائجها وليس
حتى المبادره من حيث المبدا او او ليس حتى
البنود كما يقول ضيفك الكريم ف فليس غريبا
ان تكون هذه الدعوه قد تم الاعداد لها
لشهور من قبل الكيان الصهيوني مع عبد
الفتاح السيسي واطراف اخرى من المجتمع
الدولي ولا نستغرب ذلك وخصوصا رفض د
الدعوه القادمه من فرنسا بخصوص المبادره
الفرنسيه والاتحاد الاوروبي مما يعني ان
هذه الدعوه التي اطلقها عبد الفتاح السيسي
ليست شيئا عفويا من
خطاب يعني لرئيس اكبر دوله عربيه في
المنطقه في الوقت الحالي رغم عدم اعترافي
به كرئيس لكن في نفس الوقت هو يمثل مصر في
المجتمع الدولي الان وذلك في منتهى
الخطوره ان يقول نحن نريد سلاما دافئا
ونعلم جميعا ان اي مبادره او اي او اي
حوارات حول مبادرات للسلام مع الكيان
الصهيوني لابد ان تكون من منطلق قوي او من
منطلق قوه او يكون لديك بعض ما يدفعهم الى
التنازل او حتى الاعتراف باشياء هم رافضو
من في كل المبادرات بما فيهم المبادره
السعوديه التي قامت بها في الرياض من قبل
دكتور رو تقول يجب لاي مبادره او دعوه ان
تنطلق من منطلق قوي سيد عبد الستار انضمام
زعيم اسرائيل بيتنا المتطرف اكدور ليبرمان
لحكومه نتنياهو راه كثيرون كما ضيفنا من
تورونتو بانه صفعه موجهه
لسيسي والجميع يعلم ليبرمان ودعوته لضرب
السد العالي في مصر وبالتالي السؤال هنا
حكومه فيها نتنياهو وليبرمان كيف يمكن
للسيسي ان يسوق اي تفاوض معها امام
الفلسطينيين والله يبدو يا فيروز انه نحن
الاهانات لا تؤثر فينا كثيرا
يعني نتنياهو قام بتعيين ليبرمان بعد حديث
السيسي وهذه اهانه كبيره طبعا كما حصل في
بيروت عام
2002 القاده العرب او الحكام العرب كانوا
ينشغلون بصياغه مبادره عربيه
خيانيه واسرائيل قامت باجتياح الضفه
الغربيه دخلت الدبابات والمدافع
والمجنزرات والى اخره الى مختلف مدن الضفه
الغربيه لم تحترم اسرائيل كل الحكام العرب
الذين كانوا يجتمعون في بيروت فكيف بها
تجتمع بالسيسي
المشكله انه مصر اكبر دوله عربيه السيسي
لا يستطيع ان يستوعب ذلك لا يجوز له ان
يقدم اهانات لمصر مصر هي الدوله الكبرى
التي تستند عليها الدول العربيه وبالتالي
يجب ان يكون موقف مصر بقدر حجمها موقف مصر
اقل بكثير من حجمها وكما قلنا انه قزم
كثيرا ثم ما هو السلام الدافئ الذي يتحدث
عنه السيسي
يعني ماذا تركت اسرائيل لكي يكون هناك
سلام دافئ ماولا شي ما ظلت ما ضل شي سيطرت
على الارض وتبني المستوطنات وتعتقل الناس
وتعذب وتقتل بدم بارد وكل هذه الاعمال
تقوم بها اسرائيل وكثفت اسرائيل اجراءاتها
ضد الشعب الفلسطيني منذ مبادره بيروت لعام
2002 وكلما قام قائد او حاكم عربي بمبادره
تجاه اسرائيل اسرائيل تواجهه بالاهانات
فما ذا عن ماذا يتحدث السيني السيسي وكما
يبدو لا يعلم انه نهج المفاوضات قد الحق
بنا نحن الشعب الفلسطيني اضرارا كثيره
وورط في كثير من الازمات ومازال يورط حتى
الان وحتى المصالحه التي تتحدث عنها يتحدث
عن الرييس ب المصالحه المصالحه سببها
اتفاق اوسلو الاتفاقيات والمفاوضات
والتعاون والتنسيق الامني مع
اسرا المفروض ان يقيم الامور نعم ساعود
وتالي يصدر
كلاما وضح تماما سنعود اليك مضطرون الان
ان نذهب الى فاصل قصير سنعود بعدها
مشاهدينا الكرام لمتابعه حديثنا عن هذه
الحلقه وكيف يمكن تفسير مسارعه نتنياهو
الى الترحيب بمبادره السيسي في مقابل رفضه
مبادره فرنسيه لاحياء عمليه السلام ابقوا
[موسيقى]
معنا
اهلا بكم من جديد في هذه الحلقه من برنامج
ما وراء الخبر التي تناقش زياره وفد
اسرائيلي للقاهره بعد اعلان السيسي سعيه
لاحياء عميه السلام بين الفلسطينيين
والاسرائيليين مباشره الى القاهره وضيفنا
من هناك سيد مجدي شندي سيد مجدي بالفعل
نتساءل عندما تقبل اسرائيل وتسارع وترتمي
في احضان مبادره يعلم الجميع بان
الاسرائيليين يفكرون بمنطق المصالح اي ان
مصلحتها حتما راتها في هذه المبادره التي
يطرحها اليوم السيسي وتقبلها وترفض
المبادره الفرنسيه والسؤال ما الفرق ما
بين المبادرتين ولماذا زحمت المبادرات هذه
واين مبادره السيسي من مبادره عربيه تحدث
عنها ضيفنا الكريم من رم الله السيد عبد
الستار اولا كل المبادرات العربيه هي تصب
في اتجاه واحد كلها تقوم على القرارات
الدوليه هذا ا يمكن ان انظر لهذه الدعوه
على انها تجديد للمبادره العربيه او
محاوله لاعطاء زخم ايضا ل المبادره
الفرسيه يعني تجديد من اي ناحيه نود ان
نفهم ولا احد يعلم تماما تفاصيل هذه
المبادره والكثيرون اصلا يلومون على
المبادره العربيه بانها في حدها الادنى ما
الذي يمكن ان يقدم لنتنياهو وليبرمان
ويرضي ان عنه من خلال مبادره
السيسي اولا قلت انها دعوه حتى هذه اللحظه
وليست مبادره لان المبادره تعني تفاصيل
الشيء الثاني انه الكلام عن انه نتنياهو
ليبرمان وغيره اسرائيل تتعامل دائما كدوله
واحده ماذا اخذ العرب من المعتدلين
الاسرائيليين غير الكلام والاوهام
والاحلام الفارغه وياخذون ايضا من
المتطرفين
لا على على الاقل عندك نموذج بتاع مناحم
بيجن هو من ابرم معاهده لام او معاهده صلح
بين مصر واسرائيل اسرائيل او الكيان
الصهيوني هي كيان واحد سواء
ا كان على راسه متطرفون او على راسه ما
يوصف بالحمام او المعتدلين وليس هناك
معتدل اصلا في اسرائيل لانها كلها دوله
عصابات قامت على الغزو والسطو واستلاب
حقوق الاخرين ف فبلاش نفرق بين احد واخر
في هذا الك وضح تماما لم يبقى معي من
الوقت للاسف سوى ثلاث دقائق اتحول دكتور
ثروه نافع قبل ان اعود للسيد عبد الستار
لا اختم معه دكتور ثروت يعني انت ذكرت
نقطه
جوهريه سبب ارتماء اسرائيل وترحيبها
وتشجيعها المبادره السيسي وانها تقدم
تنازلات اكثر ما الذي يمكن ان يقدم اكثر
للاسرائيليين
لا الكثير الكثير يعني لم لم يستطع اي
حاكم عربي وخاصه من حكموا ومصر ان يقدموا
تنازلات عن فكره حتى العقيده العسكريه
للجيش المصري يعني تغيير العقيده العسكريه
للجيش المصري دي من اكبر الاشياء التي
ممكن ان تقدم والتي قدمت بالفعل الان
لاسرائيل توطين اعاده توطين الاسرائيليين
في سيناء وما نسمعه كثيرا في هذه
الاجواء الفلسطينيين في
سيناء كثير يستطيع ان يقدمه واذا كانت هذه
دعوه واذا كان يدعو الى دعوه كان الاولى
به ان يدعو الى او ان يرك ز دعوته على
المصالحه الفلسطينيه الفلسطينيه قبل ان
يوجه دعوه وكانه طرف محايد مصر لم تكن
ابدا طرفا محايدا في محايد في هذه القضيه
نحن مع الفلسطينيين قلبا وقالبا الكيان
الصهيوني كيان مغتصب نقف بجوار
الفلسطينيين ضحى اجدادنا واباؤنا وشهداء
لنا من اجل الدفاع عن القضيه الفلسطينيه
القضيه الفلسطينيه في قلب كل مصري وفي عقل
كل مصري وما يفعله عبد الفتاح السيسي
تقزيم لحجم مصر في هذه القضيه ولا يمكن
لمصر ان تقدم دعوه بهذه المهانه وبهذه
الطريقه وهي تعبر عن مصر من اجل ارضاء
كيانا اعتقد ان عبد الفتاح السيسي يدفع
فاتوره ترويج نظامه من خلال الاسرائيليين
في الخارج فعليه ان يقدم الثمن من خلال
هذه المبادره او الدعوه الكريهه التي لن
تقبل على الصعيد المصري من خلال التطبيع
او الشعب المصري او حتى على صعيد الشعب
العربي السيد عبد الستار يرفض السيسي
المبادره عفوا يرفض نتنياهو المبادره
الفرنسيه ويرحب بمبادره السيسي والسؤال
اين المبادره العربيه من كل هذا ما مصيرها
هل مبادره السيسي تطوير شيء جديد للمبادره
العربيه ام شيء مختلف ما
قراءتك اولا فيروز اسرائيل بعد حرب عام
1900 167 قالت للعرب اذا اردتم حلا فقط من
خلال المفاوضات الثنائيه
المباشره مصر فرت من الحظيره مبكرا في
السبعينات لكن عام
1991 قبل العرب بالشرط الاسرائيلي في
مدريد فذهبوا كل كل وفد على حده ومن ثم
بدات المفاوضات الثنائيه المباشره لماذا
لانه كل طرف عربي سيكون اضعف مما لو كان
العرب مجتمع ا فلهذا السبب اسرائيل لا
تريد ان تعيد القضيه الفلسطينيه الى
المحافل الدوليه المحافل الدوليه الامم
المتحده تعطي
الفلسطينيين افضل بكثير مما تعطي المبادره
العربيه ومما يعطي اتفاق اوسلو ومما يطلبه
الفلسطينيون الامم المتحده تطلب تعطي
الفلسطينيين اكثر بكثير مما يطلبه تطلبه
السلطه الفلسطينيه اشكرك وبالتالي اسرائيل
حذره من هذا الكلام اما بالنسبه للمبادره
للكلام المصري طيب تفضلي للاسف ستكون لنا
فرصه اكيد سيد عبد الستار لمناقشه هذا
الموضوع معك السيد عبد الستار قاسم الكاتب
والمحلل السياسي اشكرك جزيل الشكر كنت
معنا من نابلس كما نشكر جزيل الشكر دكتور
ثروه ناف عضو لجنه الدفاع والامن القومي
في مجلس الشورى المصريه السابق ونشكر جزيل
الشكر ضيفا عبر سكايب مجدي شندي رئيس
تحرير صحيفه المشهد
الاسبوعيه ختام حلقتنا هذه دمتم في رعايه
الله وحفظه والسلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
ت